on parle de l'éthicien il ya une
histoire il yal'affaire laetitia avec
son nouveau compagnon
oui il semblerait qu'ils aient une
soirée qui s'est tenue samedi dernier à
los angels à ce soir samedi soir pour
être précis dans la villa dans la villa
que l'église est partagée alors avec
johnny alors qu'est ce que c'est honteux
mascarade je vais préciser alors là
c'est le c'est un scoop du magazine oops
figurez vous il a c'est un scoop
non non mais c'est la vérité en plus il
se trouve qu'ils ont fait un grand dîner
voilà le baiser ce qu'ils font rappeler
comme lady diana est scandalisé en fait
c'est un dîner qui a eu samedi soir à
malibu alors ils étaient très nombreux
il y avait une vingtaine de personnes
dans un restaurant thaï ses habits pour
ton fiancé que je sais pas quoi mais bon
donc c'était pour l'anniversaire de la
fille de pascal ballan donc son nouveau
fiancé qui vit à ville à los angeles
puisqu'elle est un même école que jade
l'aîné de laetitia et ils ont fait un
grand dîner pour son anniversaire
et là ils ont dîné tous les deux en face
il est témoin qui le racontent et c a
pas de problème elle lui caresser sa
petite barbe naissante comme il est
écrit etc
vous verrez ça qui est un peu qui peut
nous femmes
on sait très bien qu'ils sont amoureux
et très sincèrement amoureux j'ai déjà
parlé luigi que ces mecs bien ça me rend
un mec bien
c'est que quand même et ans et qu'il a
passé la nuit chez elle dans la maison
de johnny c'est normal pacific
palissades puisqu'à sa voiture et elle a
toute l'énergie qu'il met en scène ces
poissons à la maison de laetitia la
maison laeticia johnny magali à adé
vraiment nous venons c'est magali la
fouine donc
oui mais j'ai tout noté un parce que
donc un canyon sur pacific coast highway
à malibu un restaurant coyle merci très
tôt en campagne ils sont restés
quasiment deux heures vous dire qu'ils
ont mangé du curry au poulet oui
petite erreur quand même un poulet au
curry du poulet au curry et du peu je
déconseille fortement aux gens qu'ils
sont amoureux de poulet au curry parce
qu avant de s'embrasser du poisson à la
mangue et du thé tadjoura mont blanc et
du chant
allons-y pente et là je prends une
lotion d'investissement où il effectue
manque un message de sa zik harris
interactive ils sont en transe à ce que
montre la voiture au petit matin est
écrit là il est parti très tard dans la
nuit
ces locations la voiture il n'a pas
passé la nuit là bas le matin il y avait
plus la voiture mais par contre
apparemment il est parti très très tard
alors il alors laetitia je te défends
tous les vendredis ma chérie mais là
franchement tu vas trop loin il pas dans
la maison je n'y crois pas pas dans la
maison à johnny chan vous avez parlé
avec cyril ya quelques jours c'est vrai
qu'il ya plein de venir s'y attaque côté
là n'était celle qui s'est drapé dans
son contraire dans saab avait pleuré
voilà ça me fait pleurer et qui a
évidemment défendu son marais les
boulonnais de son mari ce qu'on peut
tout à fait entendre mais là
effectivement je pense que les fans
doivent être honnêtement catastrophé
parce que c'est tout et son contraire
franchement c'est ça vous choque ce
comportement ça va pas non plus
franchement je comprends que ça puisse
choquer des fans mais en même temps ces
deux ans après comme dit bernard est
qu'elle ira l'hôtel est-ce que c'est
pendant qu'elle était menée non est ce
qu'elle est chez elle oui est-ce que
c'est connu oui est ce qu'elle a fait la
présentation à sa famille oui donc jalae
où il est où le problème jamais ça
puisse choquer mais il ya un moment et
doit faire sa vie et les rafales ont mis
dans une voiture
sauf que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait son charme et laisser le
problème c'est que s'ils se remarier
enfin se recaser deux ans après la mort
de son mari pourquoi pas mais il ya
encore quoi quinze jours elle passait
ses nuits dans sa tombe en pleurs je
suis désolé mais je c'est vrai que les
trois qui sont énormes entre tout ce
qu'on a pu voir des semaines et des sons
le côté
mon mari me manque ce qu'on peut
comprendre et ce qui est évident il me
manque je sais pas comment faire ses
quais et d'un coup bim
elle fait des photos où elle est très
heureuse pour l atteindre il me manquera
à visionner une avalanche 4 ans elle ira
encore pleurer sur la tombe et dans 10
ans a dérapé mais ça n'empêche d'en haut
niveau alors à la haye la casse pondre
alors à la l2
ce que les gens doivent perdre ses
entrechats elle a pu voir était affichée
pendant des semaines ces barèmes ont
elles affiché un comportement quick est
très louable mais c'est la transition et
violent pas la jouer sur le registre
émotionnel
d'un côté donc là effectivement tout ce
qu'elle a fait avant vraiment de manière
douce et en bateau décrédibiliser ce
appareil peau creed sa part fo
effectivement c est crédibilisée donc
c'est pour elle que c'est dangereux
parce que les gens vont avoir
l'impression qu'il ya deux laetitia
l'éthicien public
effectivement qui affiche cet immense
désespoir et une autre laetitia privé
qui cache un bonheur sans blâmer le gars
adressé plus l'histoire avec david et
laura même pas son historie mais excusez
moi les allées les deux petites filles
moi je suis désolée elle leur infliger
des nuits sur la tombe de leur père moi
je trouvais cette façon elles vont avoir
un beau père et qui va les emmener dans
des parcs
[Applaudissements]
droit de vivre
l'attraction c'est pas pour les petites
filles c'est pour laetitia la des
besoins en finlande franchement c'est
pas parce que tu as perdu parce que je
suis en train de dire mais c'est vrai
moi mon grand père qui est ma grand-mère
est morte y avait cette phrase à qui et
à ses mails on ne refait pas sa vie on
la continue exact continue sa vie ce cas
on peut longtemps à l'avancé alors c'est
l'heure normale mais la transition et
violents pouvant non plus je vais vous
dire on sait très bien que souvent
j'étais pas d'accord avec elle sur les
questions d'héritage c'est très clair je
ne suis pas d'accord avec elle je veux
que les 4 go séries tu vois là alors ça
va être le droit français je l'espère
malgré les désirs de laëtitia en
revanche au niveau de sa vie privée elle
a raison c'est une jolie fille elle est
jeune
le mec est sympa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'est pas marié sont chance et non il
est divorcé deux fois il est libre il
hérite d'une photo de monsieur ballan
avec sa compagne 500 ex compagne avec
qui il s'entend très bien c'est marine
qui vit à los angeles avec la fsa fille
aînée célébrer l'anniversaire sada soir
non mais écoutez moi j'ai aussi changé à
claire j'ai besoin de savoir les petites
filles sont copines sont capables de
refaire sa vie mais elle en train de
déplacer par exemple le cercueil de son
mari pour aller dans un caveau familial
alors fermement en fait elle en train de
construire une nouvelle histoire d'amour
donc en fait on s'est plu à la
publication alors sachez que prépare
aussi les titienne soirée hommage à
l'olympia en début dé s'en sont à mon
avis on va pas m'aider tout de suite